so people want a lot of things out of
life
but i think more than anything else they
want happiness
aristotle called happiness the chief
good the end towards which all other
things aim
according to this view
the reason we want a big house
or a nice car
or a good job
isn't that these things are
intrinsically valuable it's that we
expect them to bring us
happiness
now in the last 50 years we americans
have gotten a lot of the things that we
want we're richer we live longer we have
access to technology that would have
seemed like science fiction just a few
years ago the paradox of happiness is
that even though the objective
conditions of our lives have improved
dramatically we haven't actually gotten
any happier
maybe because these conventional notions
of progress haven't delivered big
benefits in terms of happiness there's
been an increased interest in recent
years and happiness itself
people have been debating the causes of
happiness for a really long time in fact
for thousands of years but it seems like
many of those debates remain unresolved
with many other domains in life i think
the scientific method has the potential
to answer this question in fact in the
last few years there's been an explosion
in research on happiness for example
we've learned a lot about its
demographics how things like income and
education gender and marriage relate to
it but one of the puzzles this has
revealed is that factors like these
don't seem to have a particularly strong
effect
yes it's better to make more money
rather than less or to graduate from
college instead of dropping out but the
differences in happiness tend to be
small
which leaves the question what are the
big causes of happiness
i think that's a question we haven't
really answered yet but i think
something that has the potential to be
an answer is that maybe happiness has an
awful lot to do with the contents of our
moment-to-moment experiences it
certainly seems that we're going about
our lives that what we're doing who
we're with what we're thinking about
have a big influence on our happiness
and yet these are the very factors that
have been very difficult in fact almost
impossible for scientists to study a few
years ago i came up with a way to study
people's happiness moment to moment as
they're going about their daily lives on
a massive scale all over the world
something we've never been able to do
before called trackyourhappiness.org it
uses the iphone to monitor people's
happiness in real time how does this
work basically i send people signals at
random points throughout the day and
then i ask them a bunch of questions
about their moment-to-moment experience
at the instant just before the signal
the idea is that if we can watch how
people's happiness goes up and down over
the course of the day minute to minute
in some cases and try to understand how
what people are doing who they're with
what they're thinking about and all the
other factors that describe our day how
those might relate to those changes in
happiness we might be able to discover
some of the things that really have a
big influence on happiness
we've been fortunate with this project
to collect quite a lot of data
a lot more data of this kind than i
think has ever been collected before
over 650 000 real-time reports
from over 15 000 people and it's not
just a lot of people
it's a really diverse group people from
wide range of ages from 18 to late 80s
a wide range of incomes education levels
people who are married divorced widowed
etc
they collectively represent every one of
86 occupational categories and hail from
over 80 countries
what i'd like to do with the rest of my
time with you today is talk a little bit
about one of the areas that we've been
investigating and that's mind wandering
as human beings we have this unique
ability to have our mind stray away from
the present this guy is sitting here
working on his computer and yet he could
be thinking about the vacation he had
last month
wondering was going to have for dinner
maybe he's worried that he's going bald
this ability to focus our attention on
something other than the present is
really amazing it allows us to learn and
plan and reason in ways that no other
species of animal can
and yet it's not clear what the
relationship is between our use of
disability and our happiness
you've probably heard people suggest
that you should stay focused on the
present be here now you've probably
heard a hundred times
maybe to really be happy we need to stay
completely immersed and focused on our
experience in the moment maybe these
people right maybe mind wandering is a
bad thing
on the other hand when our minds wander
they're unconstrained we can't change
the physical reality in front of us but
we can go anywhere in our minds since we
know people want to be happy maybe when
our minds wander they're going to some
place happier than the place that
they're leaving it would make a lot of
sense in other words maybe the pleasures
of the mind allow us to increase our
happiness with mind wandering
well since i'm a scientist i'd like to
try to resolve this debate with some
data in particular i'd like to present
some data to you from three questions
that i ask with track your happiness
remember this is from sort of moment to
moment experience in people's real lives
the three questions the first one is a
happiness question how do you feel on a
scale ranging from very bad to very good
second an activity question what are you
doing on a list of 22 different
activities including things like eating
and working and watching tv
and finally a mind wandering question
are you thinking about something other
than what you're currently doing
people could say no in other words i'm
focused only on my task or yes i am
thinking about something else and the
topic of those thoughts are pleasant
neutral or unpleasant any of those yes
responses are what we call mind
wandering
so what did we find
this graph shows happiness on the
vertical axis and you can see that bar
there representing how happy people are
when they're focused on the present when
they're not mind wandering
as it turns out people are substantially
less happy when their minds are
wandering than when they're not
now you might look at this result and
say okay sure on average people are less
happy when they're mind wandering but
surely when their minds are shying away
from something that wasn't very
enjoyable to begin with at least then
mind wandering should be doing something
good for us
nope
as it turns out people are less happy
when they're mind wandering no matter
what they're doing
for example people don't really like
commuting to work very much it's one of
their least enjoyable activities and yet
they are substantially happier when
they're focused only on their commute
than when their mind is going off to
something else
it's amazing
so how could this be happening
i think part of the reason a big part of
the reason is that when our minds wander
we often think about unpleasant things
and they are enormously less happy when
they do that
our worries our anxieties our regrets
and yet even when people are thinking
about something neutral they're still
considerably less happy than when
they're not mind wandering at all even
when they're thinking about something
they would describe as pleasant they're
actually just slightly less happy than
when they aren't mind wandering
if mind wandering were a slot machine
would be like having the chance to lose
fifty dollars twenty dollars or one
dollar right you'd never wanna play
so i've been talking about this
suggesting perhaps that mind wandering
causes unhappiness but all i've really
shown you is that these two things are
correlated it's possible that's the case
but it might also be the case that when
people are unhappy then they might
wonder maybe that's what's really going
on how could we ever disentangle these
two possibilities
well one fact that we can take advantage
of i think a fact you'll all agree is
true is that time goes forward not
backward right
the cause has to come before the effect
we're lucky in this data we have many
responses from each person and so we can
look and see does mind wandering tend to
proceed unhappiness or does unhappiness
tend to precede mind wandering to get
some insight into the causal direction
as it turns out there is a strong
relationship between mind wandering now
and being unhappy a short time later
consistent with the idea that mind
wandering is causing people to be
unhappy in contrast there's no
relationship between being unhappy now
and mind wandering a short time later
in other words mind wandering very
likely seems to be an actual cause and
not merely a consequence of unhappiness
a few minutes ago i likened mind
wandering to a slot machine you'd never
want to play
well how often do people's minds wander
turns out they wonder a lot in fact
really a lot
47 percent of the time people are
thinking about something other than what
they're currently doing
how does that depend on what people are
doing this shows the rate of mind
wandering across 22 activities
ranging from a high
of 65 percent
when people are taking a shower brushing
their teeth
to 50 percent when they're working
to 40 percent
when they're exercising
all the way down to this one short bar
on the right that i think some of you
are probably laughing at 10 percent of
the time people's minds are wondering
when they're having sex
but there's something i think that's
quite interesting in this graph and that
is
basically with one exception no matter
what people are doing they're mind
wandering at least 30 percent of the
time which suggests i think that mind
wandering isn't just frequent it's
ubiquitous it pervades basically
everything that we do
in my talk today i've told you a little
bit about mind wandering a variable that
i think turns out to be fairly important
in the equation for happiness my hope is
that over time by tracking people's
moment to moment happiness and their
experiences in daily life we'll be able
to uncover a lot of important causes of
happiness and then in the end a
scientific understanding of happiness
will help us create a future that's not
only richer and healthier but happier as
well
thank you